It's time for Drew's news,
where we toast to life with our good news goblets,
or chalice, whatever you like.
Click clink.
And with me at the desk is my trusty news muse
Ross S Matthews.
Clink clink, hi everybody.
(audience cheering)
Clink clink to you.
All right, if you're a die hard for "Dirty Dancing",
well, it is time to pack your bag.
Oh my God.
By the way,
anyone remember Kellerman's in the movie?
Of course.
Hello, well Travel + Leisure reports
that you can now stay in the same resort
where Johnny and Baby fell in love.
Sign me up Drew.
(audience applauding)
That's right.
The movie is set at the Kellerman's Institute
in the Catskills.
But the real resort is in
the Blue Ridge mountains of Virginia.
And all spring and summer
you can go on a dirty dancing weekend,
complete with a movie themed scavenger hunt,
and dance lessons.
And maybe someone will throw you up in the air
and hold you there.
Yes, please.
Ross, do you have hungry eyes for this?
You did.
(Drew screaming)
It's good.
Thank you.
I remember it was one of the first movies my mom goes,
"I'm not gonna let you watch that till I watch it."
And then she was like, "Do you wanna watch it with me?"
Because it was so good.
Remember I carried a watermelon.
Oh, and she's so mad at herself too.
She's like, "That's what I said."
My girls saw it
and I was like,
"And we're gonna take a break on that one
for a little while."
Where did you take the break?
Where were you like, "Oh, well."
After it was finished, unfortunately.
But I was like, "Let me just take this DVD,
and stick it in for the next few years from now."
Do you think we could ever do the big move,
and by you do the big move I mean you lift me in the air.
Yeah Jason Kurts our Executive Producer.
Please just pick me up, let me do it.
I wish that I was the Emma Stone to your Ryan Gosling,
and we could reenact it, but I am not Emma Stone.
Well, if you're Patrick Swayze
I could be your Jennifer Gay (laughs).
I'll lift you up.
That we can do, all right.
Nobody puts Rossy in the corner.
Ever, ever.
All right, next up, we have a wedding etiquette question,
this one really got me steamed.
Okay, pulling off a wedding in the time of COVID
is nothing short of a miracle.
And I know because I'm trying to do it right now,
with planning and wowser.
Well, one writer at Insider says,
"Extreme times call for extreme measures."
Listen to this.
She admits that for her wedding
she went against all sorts of decorum,
and invited B-list guests to her wedding
last minute over text.
Mm-hmm.
So the people that didn't make the original cut
when she had more room, she was like, "Okay, B-list,
do you wanna come?"
All right, she says she doesn't regret it,
the more the merrier.
Okay, ready?
B list guests,
how dare you.
Listen, if I didn't make the cut in the first round
have a nice wedding.
And by the way, have a nice life.
(audience cheering)
Thank you so much.
B list?
Apparently she tried to do it in a really nice way,
explaining...
There was times where I wasn't
able to invite you, and then there was,
and then I've got seats to fill.
I don't know.
But the whole thing is a no thank you for me.
Right.
I just was like,
wait, it's not a seat filler event,
it's your wedding.
Thank you.
Who cares?
Exactly.
You get what you get in (indistinct) times.
I was confused and if I received that text
I would literally send back the middle finger emoji.
(chuckles) And you would,
you would.
Yeah.
Yeah, can you imagine?
Listen, it's not personal to this person,
just no, thank you.
(upbeat music)